hojae's Simpson has responded to an
interview that we conducted yesterday
with his lawyer that was attorney
Malcolm Laverne Malcolm Laverne
yesterday knock-down reports at OJ
Simpson has plans to visit the grave of
Nicole Brown Simpson after his release
now we noted that some people say the
thought of Simpson visiting the
gravesite is insensitive
mr. Simpson apparently watched our
segment from prison because he delivered
a message to us through his lawyer to
clarify that he visited his ex-wife's
graves on quote countless occasions
before going to prison Simpson says it's
judgmental to describe something he did
before his incarceration as insensitive
I think it's good that he wants to
clarify that but his lawyer made it
clear he has no plans to go but his
close friend and said on national TV
that he was going and I think regardless
of how you feel about OJ Simpson there
are a lot of people that still remember
Ron Goldman and Nicole Brown Simpson and
feel that he's responsible for their
deaths and this is a very difficult time
for them and so that was a point that
they were making that this is tough to
see I didn't know they could watch CBS
this morning
awesome it's good to know that they're
watching CBS this morning wherever you
watch it we do appreciate that